what is going on everybody welcome to
another python robotics tutorial video
in the last video we programmed our
little car here to go forward and
backwards now we actually want to make
the car be able to turn maybe left or
right so that's the next thing that we
want to do so let's go ahead and do that
so uh to start let's do
sudo nano and i guess we'll just
continue editing robot 2.5 so robot2.pi
enter and so here's our code from before
we've got our forward in reverse
and now maybe we want to get some turns
on so first of all let's go ahead and
delete these we don't need to run these
anymore we're confident that they work
now let's define
a
turn underscore left
for a time frame
one two three four our typical
initiation one two three four and now we
want to begin so to turn left
uh first we're gonna want to have 7 true
so gpio di output
7
true and then we're going to want to
have
for left 11 is true
and really everything should be true
except for 15. so gpio.output
11
true
gpio.output
13 true
and
gpio.output
15
false and now don't forget your
time dot sleep for time frame and then
the thing we forgot before
gpio.cleanup
i actually forgot the sleep and the
cleanup really
uh i guess what we'll do is we'll run
this one first just to make sure it
works turn left one so in order for this
to turn
left
let's go ahead and save yes
in order for this to turn left
since forward is on screen to go
right
to turn left would mean the closest
wheels to us must spin
to turn left so let's go ahead and run
that so pseudopython robot2.pi
and sure enough the closest wheels to us
did spin let me look at it
yep okay and they spun the right
direction so we're confident in that uh
that would make us turn left or at least
we expect that it would we have yet to
really test it
but we assume so
so now let's go ahead and
get
turn right so let's go sudo nano
robot2.pi
come all the way down to the bottom
and let's define turn underscore right
time frame
same with our initiate
and now
everything is you guessed it flipped so
false false false true so gpio.output
7
falls
gpio.output
11
falls
gpio.output
13.
false
and finally gpio.output
15 will be true
timesleep for timeframe
and gpio.cleanup
that's our turn right function
so now what we can do is we can actually
just say instead of turn left we want it
to turn right for one second
exit save yes
overwrite and now the wheels farthest
from us to make it turn right should
spin forward so sudo python robot2.pi
hit enter
and we did something wrong obviously
because the wheels closest to us spun
and they just spun in reverse uh
okay let's go let's do sudo nano
robot two dot pi
forward
turn left turn right false false false
true
let's see 11
here's what we need to do okay so 11
should be true and i think 15 should
actually be
our false
there so let's try that one oops
pi
enter
and now let's run
robot 2. pi again
okay i think we got it now
yeah that looks to be the correct
direction so let's go back sudo nano
robot two dot apply
and see what we did wrong
so
left and then turn right so the actual
difference here is um seven is false 11
true
13 and 15 are false
okay so now we've got a turn left to
turn right
forward and reverse
now the only other things that we might
want to have would be some sort of pivot
and then after that
uh we'd want a way to actually control
this rather than having to pre-type it
in so in the next video what we'll be
doing is we'll code in a couple of
pivots so it'll pivot instead of because
like when it turns like this it's going
to have to move forward that's going to
have to gain forward ground whereas with
a pivot in theory it would move just in
place and just spin in place so that's
what we're going to code in the next
video as always thanks for watching